[Music]
[Woman writhes uncomfortably in hospital bed, moaning.]
[Carol Winney:] Jerry. Don't worry, dear.
I'll be all right.
What about the kids? Who's with them?
[Jerry Winney:] They're okay, honey. Sally's
taking care of them.
[Carol:] You should be with them, dear.
They're so young, and they'll imagine all sorts of...
Why don't you go home for dinner? They'll
take good care of me here.
[Dr. Simmons:] Carol's right, Jerry. The children need some reassurance now.
There'll be a nurse on duty in this room around the clock,
myself or another doctor within call. You
better go home.
[Jerry:] All right, but I'll be back
first thing in the morning.
I love you, honey.
[Jerry kisses Carol goodbye.]
Bye.
[Jerry and Dr. Simmons leave the hospital
room as a nurse walks in and over to Carol's bed.]
[Jerry:] Dr. Simmons, what is this with Carol? How bad is she?
You've known us for years. I want you to give
it to me straight. What's happening to her?
[Dr. Simmons:] I'll be frank with you, Jerry.
She has tetanus, a highly dangerous disease.
She's going to be a very sick girl.
Right now, I can't honestly tell you how sick,
but be prepared for this.
She's going to have a rough time.
At the very best, she'll be in the hospital
for weeks and weeks.
Now you take good care of the youngsters,
and we'll let you know if there's any change here.
[Jerry:] Well, thank you, doctor. I'll
be back in the morning.
I know you'll do everything, I mean...
[Dr. Simmons:] Of course, we will, Jerry.
Everything possible.
[Jerry:] What I can't figure, doctor,
why Carol wasn't immunized for this thing?
[Dr. Simmons:] Jerry, I don't know how many
times I've urged her to be immunized.
She always put it off.
"No time this week." That sort of thing. And
now.
[Jerry:] Now is the payoff.
[The doctor shakes his head worriedly.]
See you tomorrow, doctor.
[Music]
[Jerry is seated with his children at home.]
[Jerry:] You see, the hospital's the best place. Mom will have everything she needs there.
Special nurses and all. And we'll make out
until she feels better.
[Mike Winney:] But, Dad, Mom must feel real
sick because she never gives in.
[Jerry:] Yes, Mike. She is sick. And
you're right, she has courage.
That's why I know she'll be home again in
a few weeks.
Until then, we'll just have to run the house.
[Mike:] We'll do all we can to help,
Dad, won't we, Jenny.
[Jenny Winney:] Sure, Dad. I'll do the dishes
every night. You'll see.
[Jerry:] I know you will. Well, give
me a kiss and get to bed.
Tomorrow's a school day, you know.
[Music]
[Mike:] Dad? Mom will come home, won't she?
[Jerry:] She has to, son. She just has to.
[Mike:] We'll say our prayers for her
tonight, Dad. She'll be all right.
[Music]
[Jerry, thinking:] If she'd just gotten her shots.
When I think back on how it happened, it just doesn't seem possible.
[Carol is gardening.]
[She seems to injure her finger.]
[She goes inside and bandages the finger.]
How could a little scratch like that cause
so much trouble?
She didn't even say anything about it that day.
Everything went along the same as usual.
[Carol:] Jerry, how are the hamburgers coming?
The kids will be here any minute.
[Jerry:] Coming up. Onions, pickle
relish, chili sauce, the works.
I estimated six for Mike. Do you think that'll
hold him?
Ah, here come the troops now.
[Mike:] Hey, Dad. You should have seen
the scrimmage.
I completed four passes. The last one was
about fifty yards.
Well, thirty anyway.
[Jerry:] Well, now that's great, champ.
I'm sorry I got home too late to be there.
Sit down. Dinner's ready.
[Mike:] Hey, Mom. Could you wash my
uniform so it will be clean for the game tomorrow?
[Carol:] Sure, Mike. I'll do it.
[Jerry:] I don't know what we'd do
without her.
She holds the whole family together.
You never think about something you have until
you don't have it anymore.
How long was it before she started feeling
bad?
It all happened so fast.
[Carol is making a phone call.]
[Carol:] Jerry?
[Jerry:] Hi, Carol. What are you doing?
I thought you were playing bridge.
[Carol:] Well, I'm not feeling so good.
That's why I called.
[Jerry:] Well, what's wrong?
[Carol:] Oh, I feel kind of feverish
and have this stiffness in all my muscles,
and then, well, I'm weak all over, and I have
a splitting headache.
Another thing, I don't exactly know how to
explain it, but, well, I'm so restless or something.
Well, I bawled the kids out this morning,
and they really didn't do anything wrong.
[Jerry:] Well, maybe you ought to give
the doctor a call.
[Carol:] You think so, too? Well, then
I'll call Dr. Simmons.
It's probably nothing serious, but, well,
I'd feel better anyway.
[Jerry:] Listen, let me know as soon
as you find out something, will you?
[Carol:] OK. I'll call and let you know. Bye, sweetie.
[Jerry hangs up the phone, looking concerned.]
[Dr. Simmons:] Carol, you know I'm not disposed
to be an alarmist. Quite the contrary.
But after what you told me on the phone,
I felt it my duty to order you down here on
the double.
Some things you can't let go.
Now, try and remember just when it was that
you got this scratch, and how.
[Carol:] Let's see. It must have been,
yes, Tuesday,
in the middle of the morning.
I was gardening, and something in the mulch,
I don't know what it was, nicked my finger
a little, and that's all.
[Dr. Simmons:] In the mulch? So your hands were dirty?
[Carol:] Well, you can't garden and
keep snow-white hands, you know.
[Dr. Simmons:] Yes, I know. My wife has a
green thumb, too.
Carol, you never got those tetanus immunizations
we talked about, did you?
[Carol:] No, I just never did get around
to it.
Do you suppose that might be what's wrong?
[Dr. Simmons:] Well, I don't say that it is,
but it could very well be.
We're going to admit you to the hospital for
observation and further testing right now.
[Music]
[Jerry, thinking:] What a shock it was when the doctor told me.
Tetanus. Lockjaw.
Something you never even think about.
[Phone rings.]
[Jerry:] Hello. Oh, yes, Sally.
Thanks so much for staying with the kids today.
No, I don't know yet.
But I'm going over first thing in the morning.
Oh, I surely will, and thanks for calling.
Bye.
[He hangs up the phone slowly.]
[Jerry is at the hospital.]
[Jerry:] Good morning. Is Dr. Simmons in?
[Nurse:] Dr. Simmons is in with your wife
now, Mr. Winney.
Well, why don't you step down the hall and
wait for him?
[Jerry:] Thank you.
[Nurse:] Oh, here he comes now.
[Jerry:] Morning, doctor. How's Carol
this morning?
[Dr. Simmons:] About as expected.
Jerry, I told you it was going to be a long,
tough fight.
She's going to get worse before she gets better.
We have to face that.
We've had one good break, though.
She's shown no adverse reaction to tetanus anti-toxins,
so we've been able to give her large doses
of that. It should help.
[Jerry:] Can I see her?
[Dr. Simmons:] Well, yes, but, Jerry.
[Jerry:] Yes?
[Dr. Simmons:] It's not pretty, and be very
quiet.
Any little noise or vibration could cause
a spasm.
[Jerry:] Oh. Will she know who I am?
[Dr. Simmons:] Oh, yes. She's conscious.
Sedated, but she'll know you.
[Music]
[Jerry and Dr. Simmons walk into the hospital room and stand near Carol.]
[Carol is moaning in her hospital bed.]
[She grimaces in pain, her jaw locked.]
[Jerry peers down at Carol, disturbed by her distress.]
[Carol writhes in pain, arching her neck and back.]
[Jerry:] Doctor, can't you do anything?
[Dr. Simmons:] Jerry, we're doing everything we can.
She's trying to get your attention.
[Carol tries to speak.]
[Jerry leans over her bed, trying to understand her.]
[Music]
[Jerry and the doctor leave the room.]
[A nurse presses cool cloths on Carol's face.]
[Jerry:] Lockjaw. Why does she have
to suffer?
[Dr. Simmons:] Well, you have every right
to be upset, Jerry,
but this can happen to anybody who isn't protected,
and the suffering goes with it.
Let's find a seat, and I'll give you some
background
so you'll have a better picture of what's
going on.
[The two walk over a pair of armchairs and sit down.]
Jerry, tetanus bacteria grow in the intestines of grass-eating animals,
such as horses or cows.
So, as you may guess, they're frequently found around barnyards and fields used for grazing,
but this doesn't mean they're just way out
in the country far from city life.
There are dairies in and around every city
in the United States,
and that means cows.
There are riding stables, park areas, zoos,
many different activities involving grass-eating
animals wherever you are.
Further, and this is even more significant,
when the bacteria in the soil dry up,
tiny spores are formed, each one as deadly
as the bacteria.
And they live almost indefinitely.
These spores can go anywhere, carried by the
wind,
and lie in wait for a victim,
and they're not just outdoors.
They're brought in to homes, churches, schools,
everywhere.
On shoes, clothing.
It's safe to say that tetanus spores may be
found in any room you enter.
Of course, the spores may be concentrated
wherever manure is used to fertilize trees,
shrubs, and flowers.
That's probably the source of Carol's infection.
We fear the spores or bacteria most in dirty
wounds,
such as punctures from nails, or gunshots...
wounds from automobile accidents,
but they can enter the body through any break
in the skin,
no matter how superficial.
Over fifty percent of all cases come from
wounds so trivial
that people don't even seek medical attention,
and usually involve an abrasion which is contaminated
with soil,
such as the scratch on Carol's finger.
Although everybody's exposed to tetanus
because everybody gets a scratch occasionally,
certain types of occupations are more frequently
exposed.
For example, construction workers and fieldhands,
outdoor laborers,
industrial workers in plants and factories
who work with their hands.
And then there are children.
You know how active they are.
Always falling down, scraping a knee or a
hand.
Recently, women have become more and more
exposed, too.
You see, more than ever,
they're participating in sports, going camping,
working in gardens.
They need protection just as much as men do.
Once inside the body, the germs produce a
powerful nerve toxin or poison
that causes painful convulsions or spasms
of the voluntary muscles.
One of the most frequently affected muscles
is the jaw muscle,
causing the patient's jaw to close tightly.
This characteristic symptom gave rise to the
common or slang name for tetanus,
lockjaw.
Over half the infected people die from the
disease, unless treated quickly.
I hope we've caught Carol's in time.
The terrible thing about tetanus is that it's
absolutely unnecessary.
It should never happen.
Yet we have hundreds of cases each year in
this country.
Remember when you were in the service,
and you got your tetanus immunization.
Well, tetanus vaccine is, for all practical
purposes,
one hundred percent effective,
and there's virtually no serious reaction.
Of course, you should have booster immunizations
at regular intervals.
There are no documented cases of immunized
persons dying from tetanus.
Most men get their immunization in the service.
So a big problem is with women.
They should be immunized, too.
For the past thirty years or so, immunizations
have been given to infants
in combination with diphtheria and whooping
cough.
But don't worry, Mike and Jenny have had theirs.
But there are millions of children under five
who have never had this protection.
They need immunization.
Another thing, tetanus is no respecter of
age either.
It strikes anytime from birth to old age.
There are millions of elderly people in the
United States
who've never been immunized and should be.
There would be no tetanus in the United States
at all
if everyone would get their immunizations.
But that's water over the dam for Carol.
If she pulls through this time, we'll make
sure she's immunized.
[Jerry:] You mean she could get it
again?
[Dr. Simmons:] Oh, yes. Having this disease
does not confer immunity.
You must have the toxoid.
[Jerry:] You just said over half of
the people die.
What are Carol's chances?
[Dr. Simmons:] That's the truth, Jerry. Carol
has a 50/50 chance.
Maybe a little better.
Her symptoms have progressed rather slowly.
That's on the good side.
Let's just say she's holding her own right
now.
So if there's no change tonight, there's no
use you sitting around here.
Much better you be home with the kids.
If you are needed, I'll call you.
[Jerry walks through the door of his home and looks around at objects that remind him of Carol...
a sweater, a sewing machine, a photograph, a bouquet of flowers, which he touches.]
[Jerry walks over to a chair, sits down, and throws his head back.]
[Jerry, thinking:] What would I do without her?
What would the children do?
She just can't. She just can't.
[Jenny:] Dad! Dad!
[Jerry:] Hmm? Oh, yes. What do you want,
honey?
[Jenny:] Well, Mom always reads my
spelling words to me before a test.
Could you do it for me, Dad?
[Jerry:] Why certainly. Let me see
the book.
You ready?
Uh, necessary.
[Jenny:] N-E-C-E-S-S-A-R-Y.
[Jerry:] Right. Habitation.
[Jenny:] H-A-B-I-T-A-T-I-O-N.
[Phone ringing.]
[Jerry runs to the phone and the children watch him.]
[Jerry:] Hello. Yes.
Yes, of course. I'll be there right away.
Mike, I've got to go to the hospital for a
little while.
You go next door and tell Mrs. Barnes, will
you?
She'll come over and stay with you,
And I'll see you in the morning.
[Mike:] What's the matter, Dad?
[Jerry:] They just want to talk to
me, son.
You mind Mrs. Barnes now.
[Mike:] OK, Dad.
[Dr. Simmons:] You got here in a hurry, Jerry.
Sit down for a moment, go ahead.
[Jerry:] Oh, I'm all right. Well, what's
wrong?
Is she worse?
[Dr. Simmons:] Well, she's had laryngeal spasms.
That means closing off her windpipe,
which could stop her breathing.
We've had to insert a tube in her windpipe.
It's one of the hazards of tetanus.
[Jerry:] What are her chances now?
[Dr. Simmons:] Well, the odds have certainly
gotten worse.
It's not hopeless,
but it's not a good situation.
If we can pull her through tonight,
I'd say she has a good chance then.
[Jerry:] Can I see her?
[Dr. Simmons:] If you make it brief. She's
heavily sedated. She may not know you this time.
[The men walk toward Carol's room.]
[Medical staff are bent over Carol's bed. Carol's breathing is labored.]
[Jerry pauses and looks at Carol, then approaches the bed.]
[Jerry stands next to her bed. Carol's eyes
are covered and a tube extends from her throat.]
[Moments pass, Jerry appearing deeply worried.]
[Jerry and Dr. Simmons turn to go, and the medical staff return to Carol's side.]
[Jerry sits in a chair, considering.]
[Jerry, thinking:] She'll get through the night.
She'll make it all right.
Things will be like they always were.
[The family is gathered together at home.]
[Carol, Mike, and Jenny Winney:] Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Daddy.
[Winney family:] Happy birthday to you, me.
[Carol puts drops in Mike's nose.]
[Carol trims Jenny's hair in the kitchen.]
[Carol reads with Mike.]
[Carol is shown lying in bed with her eye
bandages.]
[Jerry, thinking:] She's not going to make it.
There's no sense in kidding myself.
She's not gonna make it.
[Jerry's head lolls back and his eyes close; he seems to have dozed off.]
[Music]
[Jerry is dreaming, seeing filmy images of
nurses and brightly lit hospital rooms.]
[He imagines nurses and other medical staff, beckoning him down corridors and towards Carol's room.]
[Everything is in slow-motion. Jerry and others walk down the corridor.]
[A nurse gestures from the nurse's station. then emerges and signals Jerry to follow her.]
[Entering Carol's hospital room, Jerry sees that the bed is empty, neatly made up.]
[Menacing music.]
[A hand comes toward Jerry's face.]
[Dr. Simmons:] Jerry, come out of it.
[Jerry:] She's gone.
[Jerry comes to.]
[Jerry:] What's the matter?
[Dr. Simmons:] You're exhausted.
That's what's the matter.
Three days of no sleep finally caught up
with you. It's morning.
[Jerry:] Morning? How's Carol?
[Dr. Simmons:] Good news.
Her condition improved during the night.
She's going to pull through. We feel sure.
Why don't you go call the kids?
They're scared, too, and then come on back here.
[Jerry:] OK. I'll call. She's going to be all right?
[Dr. Simmons nods yes.]
Oh, man. What a dream. She's coming home.
[Phone rings; Mike Winney dashes to answer it.]
[Mike:] Hello. Hi, Dad.
She is? Sure. Sure. Bye.
Mom's going to be all right.
Dad just said so.
She'll come home.
[Dr. Simmons:] Well, what did the kids think
about the good news?
[Jerry:] I talked to Mike, and he was
really pleased.
[Dr. Simmons:] Good, good.
[Jerry:] Can I see Carol now?
[Dr. Simmons:] Well, it would be best if you
can wait until this afternoon to see her, Jerry.
She's still a mighty sick girl and will be
for several days.
She'll stay here in the hospital for quite
a while.
Those stiff, rigid muscles and spasms will
persist,
but they'll gradually get fewer and further
apart until she's completely recovered.
I can tell you this. We were lucky, mighty
lucky.
Tetanus is something doctors dread.
As I told you before, even with prompt round-the-clock
treatment,
we still lose about 50 percent of the cases.
And without treatment, death is virtually
certain.
[Jerry:] I just never knew. If people
only realized, this sort of thing wouldn't happen.
[Dr. Simmons:] Right.
[Jerry:] I won't keep you anymore.
Maybe I ought to get some breakfast in me.
[Dr. Simmons:] That's a good idea. I'm going
back to Carol.
I'll see you this afternoon.
[The doctor stands over Carol's bed.]
So unnecessary.
There wouldn't be a case of tetanus in this
country ever,
if people would just get immunized.
[Music]